[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
do
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
hi there i am brian wood i'm the
technical communications and outreach
manager here at wolf for bad
monza is here to talk to me a little bit
about computational essays
uh wolfram notebooks and sort of show us
some examples of
papers that have used the computational
essay format um
so let's let's just go ahead and dive
right in um
what exactly is a computational essay
what do we mean when we talk about that
so let me start this story from a very
strange position
why lots of apps
such as instagram and etc why they are
so popular
i would say the main reason is that you
know it gives you the possibility of you
know telling
a personalized story about something
okay you are the user and you want to
tell your own story
and you want to have all the
applications at the same place
like editing the video audio you know
picture capturing merging them together
you want all of them together right uh
what if you want to do the same
for something more sophisticated like
doing a computational analysis
like you read the news they are talking
about covet data and you would wonder
okay what's going on in my country
what's going on in my neighborhood
what's going on in my state
and you see like you know there are some
data but you would say now look you know
i would like to tell my own version of
the story how should i do that like i
would like to use
like text i would like to write down
some codes i would like to do some
visualizations
this is the very basic idea of a
computational essay it's basically
a computational storytelling like you
know you're using
you know programming language you're
using text you're using visualization
to tell a story in a computational way
and that is story
can be read by anyone else and that the
story can be
changed by anyone else the same way that
you know when you upload you know a
video on
any of the social platforms someone else
they can pick one piece
and they for something else so this is
somehow you know in
in short this is the very basic idea of
a computational essay
it's a platform that helps you to tell
your
own computational story on any topic
let's say topic x
it can be anything it can be coveted it
can be ugly culture it can be education
your choice your interest right so it
sort of takes that idea of a multimedia
platform
kind of a step further where it's not
just being able to
post a picture or a video but actually
being able to sort of
uh create and build these computations
yeah so i think i'd like no
if if you're okay you know i'm go ahead
and my i'll share my screen
because then we could talk based on that
so all right uh by the way like you know
you see the links here like you know
anyone you know they can just you know
use that links and you can you know
download the material that we have that
they are all public so
this idea as you said you know having
this integrated you know ecosystem that
you could
have code you could have text you could
have image you could have you know
interaction everything else that was a
very basic idea of you know war from
language
and at war from research you know you
know this company has been you know
pursuing this idea for more than three
decades
and in the past like you know whenever
if like you know let's say that you know
if you open any textbook if or if you
read any article
anything that has been used for
communication of knowledge idea
it was like very ecstatic okay
so here you can tell your story using
text
you can use code but you can also
explain your code and it can also
provide some visualizations
and the biggest benefit is that any of
these
especially you know the code because
this is the main part that producing you
know some result
it can be easily modified by anyone else
like you know you are somebody who is
seeing this code and you would say okay
you know this guy is using you know
seller automaton rule number whatever he
was saying
i'm interested in rule 30 let me explore
rule 30.
you can easily modify the code and you
can start you know working on rule 30.
so that's that's the main new novelty of
like you know uh computational essays
involved from language
it may sound trivial right now but
believe me it was a
very very difficult from the
technological point of view like you
know it took some time
to develop you know the proper
technology to have this
integrated ecosystem that they could
have everything
right at the same place so let me show
you one example
for example this is a sample of a
computational essay
so as you can see it is started with the
usual narrative text it tells a story
like
integral of gaussian function blah blah
then there is a piece of code and above
that there is an explanation
so the beauty of warfarm language is
that you know the code is very similar
to our spoken language so if somebody is
interested you know they can
just look at that so it says plot and
then we have exponential and then we
have a range and then it says you your
plot run should be here so
which is if you read this code this code
text
it's explaining the code in words yeah
and this is the corresponding
visualization sometimes you know maybe
the code
first impression oh it's too complicated
but you can you know read the code text
it tells you like you know
how the code is doing you know its job
which is basically not this simple
visualization
so in short the idea is that you are
telling a story
but this time this story is
a collaboration between human explore
like
chemistry you can explore education you
can explore kobe
you can explore your personal health
data like you know if you have one of
those you know smart
watches or apps if you have your heart
beat and etc you can just plug the data
here
show some graphs and see what's going on
with your body when you are sleeping you
know
this exploration can be done on any
topic
so at wolfram you usually say it's
computational x
and that x can be any any topic any
field of research right
yeah anything any computational subject
can have a computational essay to go
with it is
correct and essentially at this
especially nowadays
um pretty much any subject can be
computational
which which i find kind of interesting
you see a lot of things on the
wolfram community and things like that
that you
might not have thought uh to compute
about so
yeah for example like you know let me
just mention like you know one of your
essays like you know
about politics and you know uh
presidential nominees like
you would ask like what is the mains
like you know
the the topic of their interest is it
possible that you know based on the
talks that they have given at different
places can i explore like you know this
candidate
is very keen on this topic or he wants
to
do this particular thing it's a
computational exploration and it can be
done you know using this platform
yeah yeah i'm a big fan of the the stuff
in digital humanities i think it's a
real up-and-coming thing
one other thing that i would like to
mention because those who are familiar
with
one of the most important you know
crises that we have in academia because
i personally know before joining wall
from you know i was a university
professor so
one of the biggest challenges that we
had was you know uh
reproduction crisis you know replication
process
you read an article and you would say
either experimental or theoretical but
let me focus on the theoretical papers
you would say okay
let me reproduce the results you know
they're talking about the data they're
talking about the modeling
let's see first if i can reproduce the
same data and the second
what if instead of you know using this
assumption what if i
modify that tweak it to see what would
be the outcome
uh believe me like you know if you talk
with any scientist this is
one of the most difficult things to do
like
a published paper in one of the most
prestigious journals
finding the data where is the data how
we can get that data and then
translating that data into a computable
format because
yes the data is available but making
that you know computable that that's not
easy there should be proper formatting
and everything else
and then understanding like you know
what is the actual
modeling what are the parameters that
they have used how they
model you know all the interactions
this is one of the biggest challenges in
sciences
and i personally believe that you know
a good answer for this crisis is a
computational essay it's a platform that
you provide
everything that you are using to your
reader and the reader can decide that
okay you know this is the data so the
data is here
i can use this data i can change it
and i can implement it on a different
system let's see what's going to be the
result because the most important thing
in science is that
the result must be reproducible by
anyone else
if someone else cannot reproduce that it
has no scientific value
right right and it's the way you
described it is sort of a
data science workflow it's like you have
to make sure that the data is
valid and that you know it's usable
which means that it should be usable for
other people too and i think that's
that's sort of where that computational
essay comes in
you can have it all built into one
little uh
standalone kind of thing where you've
got all the data and the analytics
and then you know you can allow people
to sort of explore that on their own
since you mentioned data for example
nowadays you know one of the feedbacks
that that i get
from many of our users is that where we
can find the data about covid
like you know i want to to see what's
going on in my neighborhood like you
know i want to understand like you know
how things are evolving in terms of you
know spread is it going up is it going
down
is it the curve flattened like you know
what's going on
and people you know again you know very
similar to that
personal videos that all of us is now
using some apps to produce people they
would like to
produce their own graphs they would like
to plot you know one
parameter versus another parameter they
would like to see is there any
correlation for example between income
and the number of you know confirmed
cases is there any correlation between
i don't know the the the fraction of you
know
population with health insurance and
what's going on you know with kobe
these are very important questions that
uh professional users would like to
explore but the question is that
is it easy to find all these pieces
together
and do that simple you know analysis in
terms of a computational essay
and i believe you know well from
research we have the answer for that and
the answer is yes just to
showcase you know one case since we are
talking about kobit sure yeah this is
the resource base that that we have for
you know uh covet 19. uh
as you can see we have a very large
collection of you know curated data we
have you know geographic distribution
genetic data uh all know that but
at all from you know we have done that
and it is available
and then in addition to that we have a
collection of you know computational
essays
on many different topics if you want to
understand about some spread modeling
like compartmental models we have
some collections if you are interested
in logistic modeling we have some
collection if you are interested in
agents based modeling some simulation
even like just
visualizations like you know how i can
visualize the data
for this particular you know region or
for this particular place
if somebody is interested they can go
through all these computational essays
this
is basically our resource on the top of
that you know we have some nice
demonstrations you know
blog posts even a course like you know
if somebody is interested to learn like
you know
how they can do all of these things on
their own
we have all from you lots of courses
we have study groups they can join and
they can learn how to use
you know computational essay for any
purpose that they have
so let me show you if if you don't mind
let me go ahead and pick for example you
know let me just speak this one that
me and you will wrote so this is on
cloud
and yeah and if anyone uh watching has
has not used the wolf from cloud
uh that is something that they can uh
basically sign up and use for free
so what you just did here where you can
make your own copy of things
um basically anyone can go in and do
that yeah this is basically you know a
wall from no to going cloud like you
know that's
yeah that's what what you see here and
let me just
scroll down you know it's a simple you
know model it is a logistic modeling
that has been done you see you know it
has been done for this
region and what i did here was very
simple you know this is the original
code that you can find and i said
okay i'm sorry for zooming in
they did it for hubei region china
let me see what it looks like if i
implement it on south korea and this is
the piece that i wrote like you know a
few seconds ago
so you can instead of you know look you
know what's the difference
you are getting the data and then here
instead of going to hubei
i'm not gonna explain like you know
what's the meaning of the symbols just
quickly here i'm just saying that okay
the country should be south korea
and show me the confirmed cases and
since it is an aggregated you know data
let's look at the
daily data and i just applied
differences and i'm plotting that
you see going from chinese data
now i have the south korea's data and if
i look at that
somebody can easily see that first wave
and now second wave and thanks god you
know their second wave you know it's
going down so you see i
this was a computational essay written
for
this region but now i can
start exploring a different region i can
explore south korea
and people they can explore any region
which is available in this you know
resource data so they just need to see
okay so what do we have in this resource
data which is basically
all the data available from johns
hopkins university which is more or less
all the countries in the world
and for some countries we have to break
down for the region so
yeah it's basically the most
comprehensive data set so yeah
you can do whatever you want and you can
implement you know
the same exploration as you can see
everything is done for hubei
you can easily replace hubei by your
favorite region for demo here i did it
for the south korea
right and and it's uh it's a lot more
convenient than for instance having to
go back
and get in touch with the author and say
hey i read your study
i'd be interested to find out what it
would look like with these different
variables different parameters
you know you might end up sort of going
back and forth and
discussing that whereas in this case you
can just figure it out on your own you
can just plug in
hey what happens if i use south korea
here you know
let me let me go ahead and see what some
of these different
parameters do and you know you sort of
get that
that latitude to experiment on your own
and i think it sort of accelerates
things
you know you definitely figure stuff out
faster yeah much faster
and you know as we are discussing you
know uh i hope you know my internet
connection is
fast enough you know let's see if we can
get the
and you see like you know as simple as
that so this is the
daily data for united states you see i
just jumped from
south korea to united states you might
say no no i'm not interested you know in
the united states i would like to see
like
i don't know any other country like you
know
i say that you know you would like to
explore what's going on you know in
germany so
now you know we can do our exploration
you know for germany
so you see like you know if you want to
do a very simple you know things that i
did here you know switching
the country going from one country to
another country so germany is taking a
bit longer but
yeah you know it's like very large like
you know you can adjust you know the
date
you know the departing but again you
know that's the plot for the germany so
as you can see you know going from one
region to another region
in other programming environments
it's a headache like i really invite
all of our you know audience like you
know if you know any other programming
language
please try to do that like i really
invite you to do that
and they would see that how difficult it
is to go from
one for example region to another region
but hearing more from language
is like one line of code just
changing a few things like you notice
in less than one minute you know at
least you know we had a visualization if
somebody asked us we already know that
south korea two waves germany one wave
so like you know it's
as simple as that and this computational
you know exploration of course it can be
done in much more depth
here we just did it for a simple
visualization
yeah so uh for people who might be
interested in
creating their own computational essays
i know you've got a couple more things
where we're just about running out of
time but uh let's let's go ahead and
show
show people some of those resources that
we've got okay so
very quickly like you know we have you
know an archive for computational
notebooks
it's called you know notebook archive so
right now we have like you know a few
collection because you know these
collections like you know they are
moderated so this is somehow the best
examples that we have
and again like the other example just
need to click on that and you can
see the article you can make your own
copy
open it on the wall from cloud and you
can you know make any modification that
you want
and of course you know to make you know
our users life much easier
we design a template it's basically how
we also have a tutorial
on youtube so they can watch this
tutorial it's basically
walking through like you know what is a
computational essay how they can write
down the computational essay and with a
few click like just click on the publish
to cloud
and they can share it with anyone else
and by the way
if they use word from cloud everything
is for free like you know they can
do all of their exploration for free
like you know the same way that i did
like
make your own copy publish it share it
with someone else
or submit it to our notebook archive you
know this repository is a very complete
repository it's a permanent place for
your
computational explorations and we would
be more than happy to
receive any exploration look at the
topics
one of them computer you know doodling
you know geometry
natural you know logarithm you know
phase transition in compartmental models
world war ii bombing of innovation you
see just just look at the topics like
each one is totally different from the
other one but you can do you know this
sort of explorations in the same
platform in a simple wall from notebook
yeah and i think that's um
one of the larger goals of this whole
idea like you said with
wolfram technology in general and the
wolfram notebook
you know it sort of makes it easy for
you to
conceptualize things in a computational
way
so that even even all kinds of things
that you might not have thought of
uh you can now explore in in a little
bit more
of that interactive kind of uh
computation
so um i i think uh i think that's
probably a good place to wrap
um i appreciate you talking with me
anyone watching at home
uh let's you know feel free to check out
the notebook archive
uh we've got the covid resource page
that uh mods showed us
or you can check out wolfram community
there are all sorts of computational
essays
for the place and if you want to try it
yourself
uh obviously you can sign up for the
wolf from cloud like we said that's
a totally free thing you can do check
out that
computational essay template on the
function repository
and you can look at the youtube tutorial
um
so yeah if you if you're interested get
get started writing your own essays we
look forward to
seeing more submissions into the archive
and whatnot
thanks a lot for chatting with us today
months thank you
thanks for joining us you can check out
other wolfram tech talks live coding
streams and more on the wolfram research
youtube channel
or see what else is new at wolfram.com